Robert Tuckman has been curating five
star sports event packages for almost 20
years the one he likes recounting a trip
to the London Olympics for wealthy
businessman and his family
transportation lodging and of course
tickets to gold medal games price tag
three hundred fifty thousand dollars
which includes the eighteen percent
commission that tuck men's company go
Viva pocketed so what kind of access can
tuck and get me to this year's Stanley
Cup Finals I have my basic wish list
hime steeps hanging out with some of the
champs from the 94 Rangers team and of
course swag Tuchman zestimate fifteen to
twenty thousand dollars per person but
it's been 20 years since the Rangers
made the finals and I want more can I go
into the locker room very possible can I
ride on the Zamboni between the first
and second periods definitely can I get
Mark Messier to skate with my kids and
give them shooting tips you can get Mark
Messier certainly to skate with your
kids and give them shooting tips is it
going to happen right before the game
probably not before the Stanley Cup but
if you want to do it the next day or
prior absolutely Tuchman stumbled upon
this business two years out of college
while selling ads for a sports magazine
as incentives he would often include
tickets or a luxury suite you realize
these extras were all that mattered now
the easiest part of his job is getting
tickets designing and fulfilling the
rest of the experience that's the value
added even with the best access it turns
out some things are just off limits can
I hitch a ride with Henrik Lundqvist to
msg from Westchester from the Rangers
practice facility in Greenburgh the day
of the game probably not that's a
difficult one you know he has his
routine and I'm sure there's no amount
of money in the world that he's going to
change that cuz his ultimate goal is to
win that Stanley Cup finally I stump you